we're so used to seeing these in
takeaway shops polystyrene containers
have become key to grabbing food or
drinks on the go useful and cheap but an
environmental hazard so many single-use
Plastics will be banned in England from
October businesses will have to find
biodegradable Alternatives like wooden
Cutlery or paper cups the manager at
this Cafe in East London is worried
about the cost at a time when they're
already struggling absolutely every
piece of stock everything you see every
item of food has risen in price within
the last one year so you know this
little thing it may seem like you know
something small but it's not
the government says the public is
overwhelmingly in favor of the ban but
it's a big shift for the hospitality
sector in particular coming up in Autumn
we've worked very very closely with
business and industry because we
obviously realize there's an impact on
them and this gives them time to get to
use up stop that they've already got
because they didn't want to just have to
ditch it that doesn't really make sense
either the change follows similar moves
in Scotland and Wales packaging like
this used for Supermarket meals will not
be banned but conservation Charities
want the government to go further faster
we really need to see that the plastic
pollution tap turned off what we're
seeing at the moment now is essentially
policies that are bailing out the bath
water and and we need to see those
policies implemented in a in a strategic
coordinated approach across all of the
Nations within the UK the cost to the
environment currently is clear plastic
washing up on beaches or poisoning
Marine Wild life but now businesses and
perhaps customers will face the cost of
making our waste less toxic Becky
Cottrell Sky News